hi everyone
this is professor own dust science and
today i want to derive
the energy eigenvalues of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
the harmonic potential is an iconic
potential in both classical and quantum
mechanics
today we're going to calculate the
possible energies that a quantum
harmonic oscillator can have
encoded by its energy eigenvalues we
will see that these energy eigenvalues
cannot take just
any value instead the energy of the
quantum harmonic oscillator is
quantized our derivation will follow a
rather elegant strategy first proposed
by paul dirac
that makes use of the ladder and the
number of races
and just in case you need a little bit
more convincing this strategy is the
same one that we use to derive the
eigenvalues of the quantum angular
momentum and on top of
all of this the ideas that we will learn
today also form the starting point of
more advanced topics such as quantum
view theory so there is plenty to look
forward to today let's go
let's start by writing the hamiltonian
operator on the quantum harmonic
oscillator
although this is the expression that
will look familiar to most of you
we learn in the video on the lateral
number of races that we can rewrite this
hamiltonian in terms of the ladder
operators
like this or in terms of the number
operator
like this today we'll mostly use
these two last expressions also
we're going to use several other results
that we obtained in the video on
ladder and number operators so do make
sure that you're comfortable with these
operators
you can find all the necessary details
in the video linked
in the description if you need a
refresher before you proceed
in order to advance the theory of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
we need to consider the eigenvalue
equations of this hamiltonian
we will write it as h acting on lambda
equals e lambda acting on
lambda in this expression i am labeling
the eigenstate
with lambda and the eigenvalue with e
lambda
i could have just used lambda rather
than e lambda for the eigenvalue
but we will see in a moment that we will
use the scalar lambda for something else
and also using e lambda reminds us that
the hamiltonian is the operator
representing the total energy of the
system and that the eigenvalues are
energies so the objective of this video
is straightforward we want to figure out
what the eigenvalues e lambda r all we
know for now is that they must be real
numbers because we know that the
eigenvalues of any hermitian operator
must be real numbers but what we will
discover
is that the e lambda cannot be just any
real number
they can only take some special values
which means
that the energy of the quantum harmonic
oscillator is you guessed it
quantized the derivation itself is
rather fun
so let's get going
so this here is the eigenvalue equation
for the hamiltonian
let's rewrite this equation spelling out
the hamiltonian in terms of the number
operator
i can move the h bar omega dividing to
the other side
to get this
and then i can subtract one half lambda
from both sides to end up with this
this here is just a scalar and i will
call it lambda
so that i can write the whole thing as
lambda
lambda so what do we have
this is the eigenvalue equation for the
hamiltonian and
this is the eigenvalue equation for the
number operator
we see that both equations have the same
eigenstates
lambda here and here
the eigenvalues are not the same but
as we found here they are related to
each other in a very simple manner
lambda is equal to this and inverting
the equation
we have that e lambda is equal to this
we can also now see why we didn't call
the eigenvalues of the hamiltonian
lambda
we were reserving that label for the
eigenvalues of the number appraiser here
given these results if we figure out the
eigenvalues of the number operator
then we can use this relation to
immediately build the eigenvalues for
the hamiltonian
this is precisely the strategy that we
will follow today
we'll work with the eigenvalue equation
for the number operator here
and then at the end we will use the
eigenvalues lambda to calculate the
corresponding
energy eigenvalues e lambda the very
first thing to note
is that just like we had for the
eigenvalues e lambda of the hamiltonian
for now all we know about the
eigenvalues lambda of the
number operator is that they are real
numbers
because the number operator is a
hermitian operator
so let's move on to place some
additional constraints
on these lambda
the first constraint i want to look at
is that lambda is positive or 0.
to do that consider the expectation
value of the number of eraser with
respect to an arbitrary eigenstate
lambda we can use the eigenvalue
equation here to get
lambda lambda and we get this
the eigenstates are normalized so we end
up with
lambda let's now write the expectation
value of the number operator again
this time we spell out n in terms of
ladder operators
note that lambda a dagger here is simply
the bar
of a lambda here this means that we can
write this expression
as the norm squared of a lambda and
this is always positive of zero
bringing these two results together we
find that
lambda is larger than or equal to zero
okay so this is our first constraint on
the eigenvalues of the number operator
all eigenvalues of n are greater or
equal to zero
the next step starts with a result from
the video on lateral braces
the lowering operator a acting on an
eigenstate
lambda of the number operator is equal
to this prefactor
multiplying this new eigenstate of the
number operator
so based on this what is the action of
the lowering operator on a number
operator i can state
lambda it generates another number
appraiser eigenstate
with an eigenvalue that has decreased by
one
now this is the result that we got in
the video on ladder operators and it is
a general result
but what i want to emphasize now is a
particular case of this general result
which is that the action of a on lambda
can be equal to zero basically
killing the state this will happen if
lambda is equal to zero because in this
case the prefactor here vanishes
using these results we're now going to
prove that the eigenvalues lambda can
only take
integer values to see this consider the
real axis
and label the integer point 0 1 2 and so
on
what we will do is to draw the
eigenvalue lambda on this real axis
we already know that lambda is larger
than or equal to
zero this means we can discard the
negative region of the real axis
as off limits for lambda now let's
imagine that lambda is here
somewhere within the allowed region and
between the integers
n and n plus 1. this corresponds to the
eigenstate
lambda we can now apply the lowering
operator to this state
and we get a new state at lambda minus 1
which is another eigen state of the
number operator whose eigenvalue
is lambda minus 1. we can now apply
a again to get to a new state at lambda
minus 2.
in principle we could continue down the
ladder by applying a again and again and
again
however you may already see that we will
eventually have a problem
let's imagine that we've been applying
the lowering operator sequentially
and after applying it n minus one times
we've landed here
at lambda minus n minus one
we can then apply it again and we end up
with this new state at
lambda minus n so here's the problem
if we now tried to apply it one more
time
we would land somewhere in the forbidden
region of negative values
so clearly something has gone horribly
wrong in our construction
because we've ended up in a state for
which lambda is negative
which we know is impossible because of
this condition up here
let's reevaluate what we have the fact
that
lambda cannot be negative implies that
lambda must have a minimum value which i
call
lambda min but how can lambda have a
minimum value if we can keep decreasing
its value in steps of 1
by simply applying the lowering operator
as shown up here
the answer of course is that at some
point the application
of a must kill the state
and this is precisely what this case
here allows us to do
if we ever reach lambda equals 0 then
the next time that we apply
a we kill the state terminating the
ladder
but look we've just seen that we must
terminate the ladder otherwise we enter
the forbidden region of negative values
here
this means that 0 must be one of the
eigenvalues of the number operator
and it must be the minimum possible
value lambda min
let's draw a real axis again
we've just seen that if we start with an
arbitrary positive lambda
then in general we can apply the
lowering operator enough times
to eventually jump into the negative
region of the real axis
which is forbidden this means that an
arbitrary lambda is in general
not an allowed value of lambda because
it leads to a contradiction
instead we need to terminate the ladder
to see how let's draw our real axis yet
again we've seen that we can terminate
the ladder by making zero here one of
the allowed values of lambda
in fact the minimum possible allowed
value of lambda
as the lowering operator allows us to
decrease the eigenvalue
lambda in steps of 1 then this means
that
the only other allowed values of lambda
will
differ from the minimum lambda by an
integer multiple of 1.
and this of course means that the only
allowed values of lambda
are integers indeed if we start with
lambda
integer say n here
then by applying the lowering operator
once we get to n
minus one and we can continue in this
fashion until we hit
two then one and finally
zero terminating the ladder this
is the only way in which we don't jump
into the forbidden region of negative
values of lambda and here right in front
of you
is the solution to the question of the
eigenvalues of the number operator
so let's recapitulate this is the
eigenvalue equation of the number
operator
the eigenvalues of the number operator
can only be
0 or positive integers given this result
rather than labeling the eigenvalues by
lambda we typically use
n and the eigenvalue equation becomes
this and this whole discussion
means that the eigenvalues of the number
operator
are quantized
okay we're now ready to go back to the
hamiltonian of the quantum harmonic
oscillator shown here
in its various forms we first write down
again
the eigenvalue equation for the number
operator
remember that at the beginning of the
video we discussed that the hamiltonian
has the same eigenstates as the number
operator
so we can write down the eigenvalue
equation for the hamiltonian
like this we also argued that once we
have the number operator eigenvalues
we can immediately build the energy
eigenvalues they're simply given by h
bar omega times
n plus one half where of course n is
zero or a positive integer
so this is it the energy eigenvalues of
the quantum harmonic oscillator
are quantized let's draw our
real axis again and now we're going to
place the allowed
energy eigenvalues on it the lowest
energy eigenvalue corresponds to n
equals zero and is simply
one half h bar omega here
the second corresponds to n equals one
and is three halves h bar omega here
the next one is for n equals 2
and it's 5 halves h bar omega
and so on each possible energy
eigenvalue is separated by an
energy h bar omega from neighboring
eigenvalues
we call this h-bar omega the quantum of
energy
it is the minimum energy that we can add
or remove
from the system if we think about a
classical harmonic oscillator
if we were to measure its energy any
positive value would be possible from
zero
to in principle infinity we see that the
quantum harmonic oscillator is very
different
if we measure its energy we can only
obtain one of the discrete values
on this axis in addition
the lowest energy we can obtain is not
zero
it's one half h bar omega
if we think about what zero energy means
classically it means that the particle
in the harmonic potential
isn't moving at all the fact that the
lowest possible energy is in zero for a
quantum particle
in a way means that we can never have
such a quantum particle fully
at rest this lowest possible energy is
usually called
the zero point energy and is a
fundamental feature of quantum particles
to finish i want to explore the role
that the ladder and number of races play
in allowing us to explore the possible
energy eigenvalues and eigenstates
let's draw again our real axis and let's
add some of the
allowed quantum harmonic oscillator
eigenvalues
each of these eigenvalues is associated
with an eigenstate
n minus one here n here and n plus one
there we already know how the lateral
parasites act on energy eigenstates
because the eigenstates are the same as
for the number operator and we know how
they act on those
the lowering operator allows us to go
from eigenstate
n to eigenstate n minus one
where we have removed one quantum of
energy
the racing operator allows us to go from
eigenstate
n to eigenstate n plus one where we have
added
one quantum of energy the other operator
to consider
is the number of racer in the video on
the lateral number of races we simply
claimed
that n is called the number operator but
didn't really explain
why it had that name in a lot of detail
we can now understand the reason why and
to do so let's draw our real axis again
one final time with some of the allowed
eigenvalues
this here is the zero point energy and
it is the minimum energy
that we can have in the system and we
use it as our reference energy
we then say that this eigenvalue here
has
one quantum of energy above the zero
point
reference energy and the corresponding n
is
one this eigenvalue here has two
quanta of energy this one has three
and so on therefore the eigenvalues of
the number operator the integers
n simply count the number of energy
quanta
and this is why we call n the number
operator
a quantum particle moving in a harmonic
potential cannot just have any energy
it has to be in one of the allowed
quantized energy
levels you can learn more about the
quantum harmonic oscillator in our video
about its eigenstates and you can also
explore similar ideas to the ones that
we've discussed today
in two rather different areas of physics
second quantization and angular momentum
and as always if you liked the video
please subscribe